BMW has rolls-royce and Audi has Bentley
but what does the other German luxury
car maker have to offer after the credit
crisis killed Maybach diamonds on your
CD z' but now Daimler is going to bring
back the Pullman version of its
top-of-the-line s-class plated with
armor it costs over a million dollars
more than twice the price of the most
expensive rolls-royce aimed at royalty
and the ridiculously rich the Mercedes
s-class Pohlman is what we hear in
America actually think of as a limousine
with two rows of seats facing each other
in the back and a chauffeur's cabin
separated by a privacy screen the
Pullman is going to be about 21 feet
long making it about the same size as a
great white shark that makes it the
biggest production passenger car in the
world the car is meant to invoke the
famous Mercedes 600 series limousines
used to show for the likes of the Pope
and Elvis Presley it was owned by
celebrities like John Lennon and Jeremy
Clarkson Daimler aims to overtake BMW as
the biggest luxury car maker in the
world by the end of the decade but
meeting this goal requires Mercedes
perversely to produce much cheaper cars
like the $29,000 CLA in order to boost
volume but Mercedes has to be careful to
keep that luxury luster and it's doing
so with a line of huge high margin halo
cars based on the Mercedes flagship
s-class maybe they need to balance out
the bottom end with these unattainable
luxury cars will even work its magic on
Maybach there are rumors we're going to
see that nameplate on a Mercedes at a
couple of car shows in November